-Welcome back, everybody.
I'm here with Michael Strahan!
-Yo!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-And we're about to go
head-to-head
in a game of Stic Tac Toe.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-♪ Stic Tac Toe ♪
♪ Stic Tac Toe ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
-This is just like
regular tic-tac-toe,
but with an added challenge.
Each square contains a product
from the Michael Strahan skin
and shave routine line.
[ Cheering and applause ]
You got your...
Instead of drawing an extra no,
you have to bounce
a Ping-Pong ball
and get it to stick
to the product.
It doesn't matter if another
player's ball is already there.
Whoever gets three in a row
first wins.
-Okay.
-Michael, you're my guest.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright.
Well, I'm not using those green.
I'm going to have blue balls.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
-TMI, TMI.
-TMI.
-Oh, because you play
for the Giants.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-I understand.
Giants, Giants.
-Yeah, yeah, TMI.
-I misunderstood.
-[ Laughs ]
-You didn't misunderstand.
You got it.
-I know I did.
[ Laughter ]
[ Ohhs ]
-Oh, this is going to take
a long time, I think.
[ Cheering and applause ]
There we go.
[ Rimshot ]
Bam!
[ Oohs ]
Is it one bounce
or like eight bounces?
-Doesn't matter.
-Oh!
[ Ohhs ]
[ Oohs ]
-I shoved your --
-You on another level in Vegas.
Maybe that's affecting your
Stic Tac Toe.
-[ Laughs ] What's that?
-Oh, that was awful.
[ Ohhs ]
There we go.
[ Rimshot ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Ohhs ]
-I thought --
Oh, my gosh. Really?
Ooh, no.
[ Laughter ]
Not bad, though.
I don't even know what to do.
Oh, come on!
[ Ohhs ]
Come on!
Oh, my gosh.
Backwards?
[ Laughter ]
I can't hit anything.
-Alright, let's end it.
Y'all ready to end this?
[ Yeahs ]
Oh!
[ Ohhs ]
[ Cheering ]
♪♪
-Come on, Jimmy!
[ Rimshot ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Cheering ]
[ Rimshot ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
-No, no, you got to get that.
-I got to get what?
-Three in a row.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah, Tic Tac --
-Oh, that's how tic-tac-toe
is played, okay.
[ Laughter ]
That's how you play it, okay.
You're up.
Oh, it's me?
-Yeah.
-Let's end it.
Ooh!
[ Ohhs ]
-Ah.
[ Ah and oohs ]
[ Cheering ]
What am I doing?
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheering ]
♪♪
[ Rimshot ]
[ Laughing ]
Not one ball --
[ Laughter ]
-[ Claps ]
-There you go!
The winner.
-Hey, just like
the golf tournament.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
Oh! Yeah.
-Michael Strahan, everybody.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Yeah.
Thank you.
-Michael Strahan's
skin and shave routine line
is available now.
We'll be right back
with Judy Blume.